welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the haunting of blind manor is
netflix's follow-up to the haunting of
hill house with nearly every
shot of this show containing hidden
ghosts that'll stop your heart
and then sometimes break it so let's go
back through this season episode by
episode to find every hidden ghost i
think i found
70 of them some obvious some nearly
impossible to see at first but you will
now see them every time you close your
eyelids
spoiler warning here we go okay episode
one gives us a nice road map of the
ghosts to look out for with flora's
dollhouse the rebecca doll is beside
flora's bed as becca has been possessing
her the peter quintal is beside miles
bed as quint has been possessing him
the plague doctor doll is in the
bathroom as that ghost currently is in
this moment i'll get back to that
meanwhile the doll face
child doll is by the stairwell as he is
in a brief shot in episode 5
the soldier doll is also by the stairs
as he is in episode three
uncle henry talked about seeing a
soldier ghost in the manor when he was a
kid
i had a friend when i was your age too
in this house in fact
he was a soldier and i was very afraid
of him
until i gave him a story the predita
doll is in the attic where her ghost
remains after her terrifying death viola
is under the dresser the lady in the
lake because she's outside
in the lake there's also a hannah doll
cause as we'll find out she did okay
episode one begins with edmund danny's
ex-fiancee less of a ghost really than a
manifestation of her guilt i guess you
could say that's what ghosts are
he shows up in the reflection of the
murderous london taxi when it almost
hits dany reflecting
if you think about it his own death he
also shows up again in the flat mirror
that the real creepy [ __ ] starts when
dany gets to the manor
the plague doctor appears to the right
of the staircase as they ascend
and he shows up again in danny's mirror
after miles walks in
and right behind miles during dinner
now edmund appears again in the bathroom
mirror but as dany tucks in miles
the plague doctor is behind the bathroom
door to flora's room
the director uses this split focus to
call attention to the background behind
danny as the ghost appears disappears
and reappears and as danny walks to
flora's room you can see the plague
doctor again reflected in the bathroom
mirror now as i mentioned before floor's
doll house directly parallels the
blocking of danny with the ghosts in the
house
danny's doll crosses through the
bathroom past the plague doctor there
just as danny does and i'm finished
perfect timing the plague doctor appears
again in the mirror behind danny when
she picks up the viola doll
and he appears in the shadows to the
left as dany tucks in flora now you
probably caught the plague doctor
appearing in an extreme close-up
watching danny but he's also in the
background of the scene to the left of
her now later outside when miles gives
danny the spider
the plague doctor is behind her in the
grass and when they return to the house
you probably caught her first sight in a
peter quinn up there on the terrace
but also in the same shot the plague
doctor appears in the bottom left
and then very creepy in the kitchen
during lunch a plague doctor's hook
nose juts out from the fireplace behind
them on the left now later when danny
gives flora the doll there is some
figure in the doorway watching her
and then the plague doctor shows up
again in the mirror behind danny also in
the bathroom shadows behind miles
and briefly in the closet mirror when
danny first enters that's before
edmund appears in it later then when
danny escapes the closet the plague
doctor
returns in the hallway and when she
follows the footprints outside the
plague doctor in the final seconds of
the episode appears in the mist beside a
tree in the garden
okay moving on to episode two you
probably caught doll face in the cellar
turn it's cute little head but he shows
up again behind flora at the far end of
the upstairs hallway
and then again when danny looks for
miles at the end of the ground corridor
and then again this is scariest to me
under the kitchen table
you can see his hands on the seat of the
chair okay later in the garden behind
owen the plague doctor appears
under the window the plague doctor also
shows up behind jamie at the far end of
the quarter when she goes inside
and then edmund scares danny in the
mirror but then during hide and seek the
plague doctor appears
in the room by the window she looks
right at it doesn't see it and then in
the final minutes of this episode the
ghosts of rebecca bernita and quint
scare her as well
look i know there's a lot of clues we
gotta sift through because the best
visual clues are hiding in plain sight
just like someone's front pocket wallet
like the ridge
thanks to the ridge for sponsoring this
episode the ridge helps you carry what
you need
every day from their flagship ridge
wallet to their portable charging
commuter backpack they want you to make
the most out of what you're bringing
with you the ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
and carbon fiber
it has a clean stylish design it is
so when jason voorhees is trying to kill
you he won't be able to kill your credit
cards this is their aluminum silver
wallet
they do have other colors including some
very flashy tiki designs
this thing is light it's strong just
like you
they make it easy to buy with free
shipping and free returns and a lifetime
guarantee it's also got thirty thousand
five star reviews so you know they're
doing something right they also have
great backpacks and travel bags with
rfid blocking pockets and the optional
device charging batteries
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com
new newrockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in the
video's description now episode 3
opens with a cop visit and he is useless
because ghosts are everywhere
plague doctor creeps behind danny and
hannah in the hallway
the soldier is behind hannah under the
stairs and when the cop turns to leave
doll faces nightgown is visible outside
behind the door
and when dany goes to grab her jacket
the dog its kid is also behind her in
the hall on the far left of frame
dollface shows up again at night time on
the grounds when jamie has a shotgun
and then when they go to the chapel the
soldier is in the dark dark shadows on
the far left of frame
the soldier also shows up in rebecca's
classroom flashback i love this this is
right after we see his doll beside their
dolls the soldier also shows up again
in the lightning flash behind rebecca in
the kitchen then the doll face appears
to the left of danny the next morning in
the shadows there and then
one of the creepiest sightings dollface
is reflected in the mirror of flora's
bedroom
turning to watch danny go after the
doctor leaves you can see in the
background behind danny in the hallway
that is the soldier standing against the
wall
and then in the kitchen the plague
doctor hides in the distant background
behind hannah
along with if you look over there behind
the bin that's doll face okay episode
four
edmund scares dany when she's prepping
for owen's mom's funeral and then also
later at the sink but
dollface also shows up here he's
crouched behind that chair behind
jaime and then shortly after this under
the stairs is a new ghost with knee-high
socks later when danny kisses floor
goodnight dollface shows up to the right
of the dollhouse again turning to watch
her go and when danny confronts edmund
at the campfire the soldier appears in
the clearing behind her on to episode 5
when the wind graves arrive knee sox
ghost can be seen in the doorway of the
chapel way back there
and when hannah turns to go back inside
the time jump occurs this is an
interesting one the vicar that is the
one who married viola and her husband
and tried to give last rites to viola
he's to the far right of the staircase
but on the other side of those stairs in
the chair
is doll face looking up at us and doll
face shows up again
in his favorite hiding spot to the right
of hannah in the kitchen episode
six when uncle henry tells a story about
the soldier that same soldier can be
seen in that closet mirror facing to the
side
later in the bathroom on the far left
you can see the vicar watching flora
sleep
and as dany leaves the room before she
turns around probably got this doll face
playing with that dollhouse
and then as danny chases flora up into
the attic the soldier
and the vicar look down on her from the
sides of the steps
in episode 7 there is a subtle shadow
behind rebecca as quint talks to her i'm
sure that's something
and then episode 8 when perdita passes
viola's portrait it briefly bears his
sinister
face before changing back and when viola
drags quinn into the lake you can see
a figure in black appearing in the mist
behind her and finally in episode nine
the ghost sightings drop because you
know most of them are freed except of
course for the lady in the lake
sightings haunting
danny in the florist door in the water
pitcher in the sink
and in the bathtub and of course our
final ghost sighting our closing shot
danny's hand on jamie's shoulder oh
still scary
comment down below with the creepiest
ghost sightings to you in this series
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
at eavos follow me rockstars thanks for
watching
[Music]
you